hey guys welcome back to another episode
of awesome build where this week we're
going to be building jyn erso
blaster from road one
[Music]
well as you may or may not have guessed
by now I'm a pretty big star Wars fan
and rogue one comes out this week ever
since the first teaser trailer got
released we saw just a glimpse of
generous hose blaster I've been wanting
to do this bill I could tell right away
that it was built around a German Luger
with like a barrel extension but that
was about it I couldn't get any real
clear images of just the gun or any
close-ups of it online for a long time
in the last few weeks are more of them
popping up mostly other people's
interpretations or other people's
versions of the bill that combined with
some screenshots and some artwork and
stuff like that that I've seen so using
that I'm going to do my best to try and
make as close to a movie accurate prop
as I can fortunately I do have a replica
of a Luger which the body of the gun is
built around however I'm going to have
to be doing a lot of modifications to
this I don't want I'm probably going to
cut the barrel down I'm going to have to
grind some pieces out screw pieces onto
it and I'd rather not ruin a perfectly
good replica so we're going to use this
and make a two part mold using the same
materials that we talked about in the
previous episode only this was going to
be two parts and we're going to pour our
resins into it and get an exact copy of
this Luger so it'll be made out of resin
leaving hard plastic but it'll be easier
to sand and cut and grind and I don't
have to worry about ruining a perfectly
good replica I just have to pour about
$15 worth of resin into mold so as I
said the rest of the component can be
pretty simple they can ever be things
that you can buy at the hardware store
the barrel size that I'm going to go
with I think I'm going to use a 3/4 inch
PVC and the 3/4 inch PVC coupling we're
also going to be using some half inch
PVC I'm just going to cut the tip off to
fit for the tip of the barrel and then
for the ribbing there's some like
machining and ribbing on the barrel
rather than doing any machining and
stuff on this PVC and really have
materials I only have the tools to do
that
I would have to do it by hand which
would take a lot of time so instead I'm
going
use this piece of flexible tubing as the
ribbing is really close together I got
this at Home Depot while back and I've
used it for different projects and stuff
like that so I have a bunch of this hose
but it was pretty inexpensive and then
we're also gonna be using some various
size dowel rods and we'll be kind of
hanging it all together using super glue
and jb weld plastic weld so the first
process is we have to make the gun by
pouring our resins into our mold so
let's take a look at it so in the future
I will be doing a tutorial on making a
two-part mold it's very similar to the
one part mold obviously but when making
a two-part mold you have to build
registration keys into your mold so that
the two pieces fit together the same way
every time that way don't get any
shifting or anything like that in your
mold then here I'm just and whinging the
two pieces between some scrap plywood
and clamping it down so that is airtight
has to be careful not to clamp it down
too much so it doesn't compress the mold
and warp or miss shape the outcome a
little and this is the same practice
mixing up the resin
I'm pouring them into our mold and once
the most cures open it up and see you
again and as you can see it's a pretty
good duplicate of the Luger now you
could use certain residents to add
pigment so if you wanted to you could
make it all black right out of the mold
or in color the two arms I just had some
white that I had to use up then so
that's why I want to be Czerny and cut
off our excess plastic and after sanding
and shaping is it to go
I took my rib toes and I cut a little
bit more than the length that I wanted
to go similar it's going to fit into my
3/4 inch PVC coupler the diameter of the
hose is actually a little larger than I
needed I wanted it to be the exact
diameter of the 3/4 inch PVC so I cut
the section out of it now my 3/4 inch
PVC and measured out the distance in
which I wanted the holes to be in the
sides of the gun using an architect's
ruler it kind of helps out to get
straight even - once I knew exactly
where I wanted my holes to be
a drill team small pilot holes to make
sure that everything is lined up I'll
then gradually use larger fists to open
up the hole once I had at one side
perfect I'd done use my drill press to
drill through those holes through the
other side
let everything lined up evenly using
some two-part epoxy and mix it up here
and then or glue this dowel rod to the
body of the gun as you can see I cut the
barrel of the gun off and drilled a hole
into the dowel rod and the body of the
gun I then took metal rod and that's
going to go inside the gun and the dowel
rod tie it together and hold it will
secure
[Music]
now once that's dry I'm going to fit my
piece of rib hose over the dowel rod
using some hot glue I'm going to glue
that into place and as you can see I
left a little bit of a gap underneath
and the reason I did that is because
there's going to be another kind of
black piece that fits underneath the
barrel and I want that to kind of slip
into that cool
[Music]
all right I get my holes drilled
half-inch PVC on the tip and then my
coupling I cut in half and that's going
to be the part that ties that part of
the barrel in with the ribs part that
clear plastic is some scrap discarded
plastic tubing that I cut to fit inside
the barrel so that it closes up both
holes now the piece that goes underneath
the barrel I first cut out of a piece of
scrap foam board once I thought I had
the dimensions right I then traced this
on to scrap pieces thermoforming plastic
that I had and cut it out once
everything was sanded and ground down to
where it looks pretty close to the
gunch's that I had and then had to clean
it up a little bit and there's a hole or
kind of like a slot in the middle of it
I drilled out and then file down this
was a little time-consuming part I think
on the whole darn little fish black
bracket perfectly does it select these
that goes our needs a girl it took a lot
of sanding and grinding to make sure
that everything looks right place clean
and that it was going to fit just right
underneath the barrel
what does have a way of God's mazanik it
right
I then glued the front of the barrel to
the rib part after it done this I
realized I still needed to grind out
part of the gun
I probably would have done this before
actually having glued the barrel on
using some more of the two-part epoxy a
children x-rays and applied some to that
plastic piece of Independence apparel
I had it all lined up and let that sit
here
I then took another to this track
plastic Andrew there's another kind of
bracket that goes on the side of the gun
where we kind of ground out phrase
period once I cut that out because in
3/4 inch PVC cut it in half now this is
going to be the top part of that bracket
[Music]
as beneficial to the television and I am
busy at breakfast
I feel I hold
[Music]
and it looks like we use Rivest
that's at the rivet and I'm just going
to cut the end off and clear on to the
bracket I just usually with superglue we
will visit in now on the other side we
kind of ground down I'm going to drop
out the shape of the bracket that I want
the reason why I'm doing this is I say I
decided to use these plastic wells of
self system rather than cut it out
because it actually had to be a little
thicker
and tie into the PVC see security longer
style I wanted it's a blend game
seamlessly but I thought that this would
be the best
[Music]
once I spoke with the basic shape and it
cures I can stand it this nice and clean
too
and the lines blend in well without PVC
[Music]
I've been also then drill it and add our
rivet
the body of the gun is finished now
we're ready to change I use trial on I
use the black satin finish that one of
the gun is going to have a little bit of
a shine to it
however I want to form over the gamers
done little great that's how we could
have started out with it apply black eye
then take off all of the areas that I
wanted to keep black and said I want to
do a metallic look one over with the
brush detail
[Music]
all right so this is it I'm gonna
overall I think it turned out pretty
well I'm pretty happy with the way it
did look there are a few things I would
change about it there's the overall look
I think it is pretty solid there's some
detailing and things some little minor
things that I would go probably go in
and clean up a little bit I may go in
and do a little bit of detailing and
weathering on some of the parts and
stuff like that but for right now I'm
actually kind of happy with the way it
looks kind of like almost right out of
the box have you guys enjoyed this
episode this is a really fun build for
me to do and it was actually a little
more difficult than I thought it was
going to be I knew it wasn't going to be
easy going in if it's a clean it's a
simple design but it's got a lot of
nuances and details and stuff like that
in it that I knew I was gonna have to
pay a lot of attention to so it was a
little challenging actually I did run
into some hiccups here and there but
ultimately I'm happy with the way it
turned out I hope you guys found this
entertaining and/or informative I hope
it inspires you guys to go out and bills
and make some tops of your own as always
don't forget to look me up on Facebook
at James Jim Jerez thank you guys so
much for watching and supporting the
show you guys rock I'll see you next
time
[Music]
you